oh [ __ ]
uncle Joey coming at you from Radio
mother [ __ ] chaos smoking token but
Bokan it's Monday mother [ __ ] wash
your pussy's top and body a soul stain
[ __ ] around out there today uncle
Joey here with his little half of green
shirt on but what are you gonna do
things are bad all over him saying at
least I acknowledge that off the bat
nobody had to tell me uncle Joey what's
up with that [ __ ] lime gene that lime
juice flopped in the shirt we will Porto
Rican [ __ ] frog or something anyway
it's a beautiful day to be alive I got a
lot of [ __ ] on my book today I got a lot
of people today people get launched to
people with jumping off windows I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm on a mission from
[ __ ] Satan and I'm sure you're on
your own little [ __ ] mission but
Joey who are you [ __ ]
you know spark that [ __ ] soldier
some days I'm the man of many reefers
today I want you exclusive from [ __ ]
such a terrible still taking me to the
next level of [ __ ] you know anyway
it's Monday a [ __ ] to do
and so do you follow me I hope your
weekend is good I hope you got your
balls licked and you dick suck like
maybe in 95 but it's a whole different
[ __ ] week it's a whole different
[ __ ] battleground if you're not
prepared as usual you'll go [ __ ]
under if you're prepared if you wrote
your goals you'll smooth out the week
with a flop you lose I'm [ __ ] Friday
night you got my birthday weekend but
joy but you to chitter-chatter spark
that [ __ ] soldier don't twist
my arm
we got the podcast the Church of what's
happening now at night 8 o'clock be
there or be square younam's I'm we got
[ __ ] to do and people to see
with Joey Sparky
this [ __ ] pipes kicking like a
mule today
I'm sending smoke signal to the whole
[ __ ] I tell you what you know he's got
my smoke signals the people looking for
the Egypt to [ __ ] flight and get the
smoke signals from Studio City what are
you crazy
or nuts Oh yet sparking like a
[ __ ] I gotta show up with a big
dick and a big hug I'm saying today's
the day you tell the water suck your
dick it's business as usual and you
don't give a [ __ ] during that time for
hope he dope stories you don't give a
[ __ ] what happened in the endless the
[ __ ] American Music Awards what a
[ __ ] embarrassment embarrassment
that's that [ __ ] pink flying around
the air like a [ __ ] which when lit on
fire she didn't know what to do she was
smelling hot dogs and had that [ __ ] a
down one yet
oh jesus [ __ ] christ that that kid
jumping around running around
lip-syncing by justin bieber lip-syncing
what is the world of music [ __ ]
Cummington thank God for the church
what's happened now keeping it real with
the [ __ ] Bible of rock'n'roll so you
got no misunderstanding you got Brahman
music just to lend a little Joey I'll
set you straight that [ __ ] oh my god and
young kids would but dad I look like a
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] bomb in her and
Stevie won the state of [ __ ] home he's
about eight hundred [ __ ] pounds
enough enough he's out there [ __ ]
walking it what the [ __ ] I can't take it
no more beat
look at Turkey but Jim Zane what's this
read for such cooking your [ __ ] in
trouble cuz then we go deep deep deep
until the murky waters with a
[ __ ] underworld Jack turned up
to you either write your go to it you
could make a plan we'd end up try to get
[ __ ] in the ass by Cosby's nephew with
no bill seems like it's up to you
there you go
I don't respect myself with Dikhhla
today's up to 9 8 o'clock tomorrow night
I'm taping an already show this is not
happening at the cheetah
I think tickets are available get your
[ __ ] asses down there Thursday I'm at
the store that's it for right now you
have another podcast Wednesday call it
don't man in the world the [ __ ] uncle
Joey Diaz unit 53 ugly and ever anyway I
got [ __ ] to do people to see at a more
we from this small I gotta do backflips
today and [ __ ] it man hip escape you
know me I'm a man of many occupations
I gotta take two steps to the rear and
get out of here right I love you
[ __ ] don't forget about me
8:00 p.m. tonight I'll preacher like a
7:30 maybe some [ __ ] mushrooms
tonight maybe some fine edibles it's up
to you it's up to you you know I'm with
you you're with me and they want to be
with us with a [ __ ] Church [ __ ]
family they can't stop does she
understand they need a [ __ ] bomb you
gotta show up with Isis with [ __ ]
suicide bombers but we're ahead of them
we're ahead of my land [ __ ] suicide
bombs anymore what do you guys get me
all [ __ ] up we seem I'm jealous I'm
I'm gonna end up in a rehab because of
you [ __ ] out here talkative
smokin I love you have a good day keep
your eyes open don't take no [ __ ] from
nobody [ __ ] these [ __ ] they put
their pants on I got a time like you if
they can't take a joke take the shuttle
get the fly out of my face [ __ ] I'm an
American you understand
stay back